hey everyone welcome back to the game
spot III stage I'm your host Mike my
Hardy here with Justin hey Wald hello
and Dan greenwalt the creative director
on the Forza franchise how's it going
good
you must have a good week forts a
Motorsports seven is out in the open now
for Microsoft's press conference yeah it
was a it was an incredible moment I mean
it's loose it was kind of historic we
unveiled a flagship supercar here at e3
the 911 gt2 RS yes unveiled on stage and
that's never happened before
I mean we've shown cars before it forts
on the stage but it's never been a world
debut of a car and that's not because of
Fortson that's actually because of
gamers yeah the rise of gaming has been
incredible it's mainstream now and
that's what Singh created this this
amazing experience and there's more
coming this weekend we're actually our
racers the forts are racing championship
eSport racers will be at the 85th
running of lamont this it's the
Superbowl of sports car races and
they'll be taking the podium alongside
the other winners of the of the real
race it's a it's incredible to think
what has changed in gaming over the last
10 or 15 years and yet what's in
particular like really pushes the the
realism of cars and driving and racing
and that has to come from a passion for
for those vehicles absolutely I mean the
team is passionate about technology it's
passionate about games it's passionate
about cars I happen to be kind of in all
three camps so I'm in the the perfect
spot there but yeah we we love to be
involved in cars and motorsport but you
know the the creative director on the
Motorsports product line you worked on
Pokemon and so we have 700 cars in this
game and there's a collecting mechanic
in the game itself so it's not just the
number of cars but though the way you
can integrate with them so having a
passion for games and then a passion for
technology when we think about the Xbox
1x the the most powerful console ever
made our team was tripping over itself
to be you know pushing that and pushing
it even harder than that anyone else
could yeah minutes before 4 to 7 was
revealed it was also the reveal of the
Xbox one X or at least you know that
that's the file name is what it looks
like this is how much it cost is when is
going to come out and then of course
like Phil Spencer toss it over to 4 to 7
what was it like kind of seeing your
game in the
4k resolution and everything up on the
big screen and what was it like making
your game with these specs in mind
well that screen was insane even during
rehearsal just looking up at it just
seeing 4k on this huge bright screen is
incredible so we we actually moved our
engine the fort Sutekh engine it power
sports our horizon and Fortson
motorsport we moved it over to PC with
Fortson motorsport six apex moved it to
DX 12 we then took that engine and put
it on the Scorpio dev kits before it was
the xbox 1x and had it running at native
4k solid 60 frames per second with
higher resolution PC assets and we still
had 30% more power Headroom to actually
play with us so it was it was amazing
and also the transition I've been around
for a while for the launch of the
original Xbox 360 and so on moving into
this as a dev environment has never I
mean never been easier we were up and
running in a day and 30% extra room over
the top which allowed us to just decide
how do we want to make the best possible
image quality and that means at this
point the game people are playing down
on the show floor for to motorsport 7
cannot be run on any other console it
can only be run on the Xbox 1x or on a
super high-end PC sure and in what's it
like moving away from like you know if
it can't be run on like Xbox one what's
it like moving away from that well it
still can so it's just that like think
of it like a PC chair so the Scorpio the
Xbox one X is like an incredibly high
end PC but it's also a fixed
architecture which means we can optimize
it and really make it look incredible in
so doing that optimization we actually
lowered the min spec on the PC version
of the game so the optimization
benefited everything it also means meant
on the Xbox one and the Xbox 1s the game
looks even better
so photogrammetry which is a technique
that's used by some of the developers
already seen on stage today that
technique actually makes the the
textures look better in the game not
only Xbox 1x but actually on the Xbox
one the Xbox 1s as well so all of the
platforms benefited and all that's just
the graphical side of course the
gameplay is fantastic and as a cross
play and X
yay game we're unifying this massive
racing audience so you can play it on PC
against people people on the Xbox one s
against people on the Xbox one X and and
have this massive community there's 4.8
million players playing every single
month in Forza it's a huge racing
community so bringing them all together
getting them excited about cars and
technology and and and racing that's
that's really the vision of our our game
yeah you were just mentioning outside of
just the graphical improvements in terms
of gameplay and connectivity how the
Xbox 1x is helping Forte's kind of
develop but I'm curious how Xbox 1x or
even I mean like I know you don't work
with Sony but like with like updated
consoles that almost update like on a PC
cycle now what does this mean for the
future of like Forza or racing games in
general I can you see this affecting
anything on the gameplay side in the
future I think it's great for us in
particular we had an engine that was
custom made for the Xbox one you know
it's a bespoke engine very high-strung
it ran really well in the Xbox one it
was a native 1080p game at a solid 60
frames per second by going to PC with
DirectX 12 with Forte's Motorsport 6
apex and Forza horizon 3 we were able to
make our engine more ubiquitous it could
work on multiple different types of
devices with different drivers and what
have you an Xbox the DirectX 12 allowed
us to code straight to the metal and
really get the most out of people's pcs
by moving our engine in that direction
taking more PC Center approach it's much
easier to take advantage of console
cycles as they move on but as a game
creator I want to get the biggest
community possible playing our game we
want to get them passionate and excited
so I don't want to leave the Xbox one as
for the Xbox one behind I want gamers to
be hungry and excited to play Forza
Motorsport 7 on the Xbox one it looks
great it's got a huge car list it's it's
physics feel fantastic so we have to
embrace this kind of development cycle
and it's a win for the gamers I mean PC
gamers now have a bigger community to to
compete in and console gamers now have
more options are you looking for
something at the right price point are
you looking for the the most powerful
console ever made
you can do either one you know speaking
of someone who's been in the industry
for a long time you've seen these shifts
and how that's affected things like
making games for the original Xbox is
very different than the Xbox 360 and now
the Xbox one and it's unprecedented how
this generation of consoles is changing
is it is it as difficult going from you
know Xbox one to Xbox 360 as it is from
Xbox Xbox one to Xbox one X or is that
kind of shared architecture making that
an easier process the shared
architecture makes all of the difference
it's a huge huge change this honestly to
the developer doesn't feel like a
console generation switch at all what it
feels like is like a new video card or
so yeah it's it's part of PC development
right so new hardware's coming in and
you want to optimize for it make a great
experience without leaving behind
players on these other consoles you want
to unify this community getting up and
running was incredibly easy and a lot of
it's because the similarities between
DirectX 12 on PC and DirectX 12 X on the
Xbox one and the Xbox one X if you're
looking at racing games you know like I
like raising you to play a lot of
different kinds of racing games
obviously like Forza is very different
than Need for Speed and then the crew 2
was announced at ubisoft press
conference and then of course you have
GG sport also on the horizon if I'm
someone that maybe sets like plays all
those other ones but isn't like
traditionally a Forza fan what is forts
are offering them that they can't get
anywhere else like what it like you're
what is it that is inviting them into
the force of franchise if they haven't
been with it since the last few games
what's really important to us on on
Forza is to bring together this massive
community and that means having a
diverse community so forts motorsport 7
has split-screen
we also have a ton of assists so you
turn all the assists off and you are
playing the most advanced simulation
you're going to find the tire simulation
alone is something that's more on the
commercial grade we didn't want to make
a choice or a compromise between Pro
race drivers using our game to Train and
having my 9 year old twin boys be able
to play the game on split-screen so we
add layers of assist that make it easier
to drive and depending on what your
skill level is you can come into it
that broadens out the type of player
that can play it so if you're looking
for split screen 700 cars I mean you
name it you know we've got all this
diversity in the car list you can come
in in any level and find your place your
painter your a tuner a photographer you
want to be involved in the auction house
this game is massive but it's not just
Fortson motorsport force our horizon as
well open world are you a core gamer you
love exploring open worlds collecting
and and finding these incredible sunsets
and again taking photographs forts or
horizon has you as well so I don't see
the games is just one versus the other
I see the forts a community and the
fort's of franchise as a way of bringing
people together around cars and games
cool I guess my final question would be
when can we play Forza Motorsport 7/4
Motorsports seven will be shipping on
Xbox one Xbox 1s and PC on October 3rd
it's an XP a game so it means you buy it
on PC and you can play it on Xbox your
achievements and save game and then on
November 7th when the Xbox 1x ships and
a Content update will come into the game
and you'll be able to play it there as
well and it's a tremendous showcase of
your HD if you got an HDTV oh my god
so Xbox what X is incredible I'm gonna
be playing all of my games onyx they all
run better but for two motorsports 7
will really show off your HDTV and the
xbox 1x great dan green well thank you
so much for coming on the stage here
today thank you awesome everybody
watching from home we will have more
developer interviews and gameplay demos
throughout the week here at GameSpot so
stay tuned we'll see you around
you